[Musique]
la moto giller
il
[Musique]
la moto giléra célébra ses 100 ans en
sa naissance coïncide presque avec la
naissance de la moto elle même
pendant près de soixante ans l'histoire
de la moto jill et r1 a été liée à celle
de son fondateur
josep et jill et rhin était un homme de
son temps il faisait partie de cette
génération qui a écrit l'histoire
industrielle de l'italie entre la fin du
19e siècle et le début du xxème parce
qu'il avait la ténacité et le courage de
tenter ils croyaient en l'avenir il
commença avec un petit garage il passe à
un autre plus grand puis un autre encore
plus grand juste après la guerre il
fonde une entreprise au bon endroit avec
de bonnes dimensions il développe son
activité au fur et à mesure de la
demande du marché
[Musique]
sur l'eau potable
schwab
sa famille était paysanne depuis des
générations
elle comptait aussi quelques rares
artisans mais lui il possédait
mystérieusement le génie de la mécanique
[Musique]
peut être oui ben
j'ai eu
c'était un homme qui s'était construit
seul grâce à des connaissances
techniques enrichi par son expérience
personnelle
surtout il était doué de grandes
intuitions
ans mécanicien très compétent il
construisit sa réputation d'abord comme
réparateur et ensuite comme constructeur
[Musique]
les causes
soit
personne sûr de lui doté de grandes
qualités humaines il savait établir des
rapports très fort avec son entourage et
les gens qui travaillaient avec lui
il sut d'une manière très naturelle
composée ce qu'aujourd'hui on
appellerait intime
j'ai un souvenir formidable de giuseppe
giller souvenir d'un homme que j'ai
presque toujours considéré comme un père
c'était un véritable chef de famille
nour département course on le voyait
surtout le soir vers minuit
on avait commencé à 6 heures du matin et
gilera à la fin de la journée disait
demain on se revoit à 6 heures du matin
et à l'heure dite ils étaient là à nous
attend
[Musique]
l'entreprise gilera né en 1909 à milan
avenue du 22 mars dans le mille ans
ancien
lorsque giuseppe gilera décide de se
mettre à son compte il dessine le
premier moteur sur lequel est monté le
même cadre que celui utilisé pour les
vélos
la démarche est totalement novatrice
le cadre est plutôt conventionnel le
moteur pas du tout
il s'agit d'un moteur à soupapes en tête
très avancées pour l'époque
la première moto conçu par giuseppe
giléra avait un moteur à quatre temps
les pédales à béton un double fonction
pour le démarrage et pour céder dans les
montées
parce que la puissance du moteur était
tellement limité que dans des parcours
un peu raides souvent le pilote avait à
pédaler
et constamment on raconte que cette moto
pouvait monter à 100 km/heure
avec cette moto il a fait des courses il
participe à différentes compétitions et
il en gagne à plusieurs
au début presque tous les artisans
étaient également pilote parce que la
seule manière dont il pouvait faire
connaître leurs motos au public était de
les engager dans des compétitions
parmi ces artisans pilote plusieurs
devint ensuite de véritables pilote
gilera a été pilote plutôt par nécessité
lui c'était surtout un mécanicien sa
passion était la mécanique
luigino qui était le frère de giuseppe
giller son beau-frère rosolino grave et
quelques collaborateurs ou amis rouler
aussi pour dealer
il y avait une gestion familiale des
courses
les pilotes italiens étaient des pilotes
du dimanche et des jours fériés
le reste de la semaine il avait d'autres
activités
en italie ont roulé sur des circuits de
ville ainsi que sur des routes entre les
villes avec comme protection des balles
de paille qui surtout servi au public
pour sa soirée être plus proche de la
course
[Musique]
l'objectif industriel de giuseppe gilera
se dessine en 1920 21 avec les premières
compétitions
ces idées sont claires il veut
construire une auto fiable et économique
il a conçu une moto de tourisme mais
monté par quelqu'un voulant concourir la
moto pouvait se présenter à des
compétitions de régularité et gagner
des compétitions de vitesse suite était
impossible
et
la cylindrée préféré par les clients
n'étaient pas là 500 mhz et l'a350
ainsi giuseppe gilera s'adapte à ce
choix du marché
en 1926 la première 350 sortie dans les
modèles sport et supersport
il avait changé les paramètres parce
qu'il jugeait que les soupapes latérales
était plus efficace
[Musique]
du cpj les reins avec son usine moins
grande et moins bien équipés que celle
de son concurrent direct moto guzzi
devait forcément misé sur un produit
plus économique pour arriver à
l'emporter sur les prix
il comptait sur les soupapes latérales
qui était à l'époque le système le plus
sécurisé en un sens le plus rationnel en
1930 n'acquittent une moto nettement
plus valable la dl500 centimètres cubes
et trois cent cinquante centimètres cube
tout en gardant les soupapes latérales
il avait amélioré le modèle sur
différents points
à 4 vitesses une lubrification plus
efficace et d'autres bonnes prestations
une des caractéristiques des motos
giller
était de s'imposer surtout dans les
compétitions d'endurance
[Musique]
ce qui consolide l image de robustesse
de la maison de production
les victoires les plus importantes
furent obtenus dans la compétition de la
cei john en 1930-31
les italiens étaient alors considérés
comme les cendrillon dans le paysage
européen dominé par les allemands et les
anglais qui maîtrisait des techniques
très avancées
cette victoire fut le premier succès
d'une équipe italienne dans cette
olympiade de la moto les pilotes étaient
les mêmes que ceux des compétitions de
vitesse le même groupe d'amis et de
proches auxquels s'étaient ajoutés me
roma faith hill belle nero appelé ainsi
pour son physique avantageux tous
ensemble ils contribuèrent à ce succès
qui reste est le premier remporté pour
la cei giorni par une équipe italienne
[Musique]
après son grand succès à la cei giorni
la course de six jours gilera décide de
se concentrer également sur les modèles
de cylindrée inférieure à un demi litre
en italie les motos faiblement cylindrée
jouissait davantage fiscaux et avait des
prix plus abordables
des portes d'art corps et serein si une
moto légère avec un moteur de 175
centimètres cubes et les soupapes
latérales
l'évolution directe de ce moteur donne
ensuite naissance à la sirion après 1934
la cylindrée est monté à 220 cm cube et
des modifications substantielles
apportées au moteur
[Musique]
les soupapes latérales dépasser arc
aurait ressenti la nécessité de
transformer la production
[Musique]
en
1934 un nouveau moteur à valve en tête
aux prestations élevées voit le jour
créé pour la route
la 500 vtb tout beau pouvait atteindre
une vitesse de 130 km heure et disposait
d'un système d'échappement avec une
seule soupape et deux conduits divergent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à partir de ce modèle surnommé 8 boulons
on a conçu différentes versions pour des
compétitions variés dans la catégorie
sport et pour les jeunes qui se
préparait à une carrière dans le
motocyclisme
[Musique]
oh
on
non
[Musique]
la marque a été créée à partir des
exigences militaires
dans les années 40 l'armée a demandé des
motos avec des caractéristiques précises
les militaires voulaient les soupapes
latérales et la transmission à cardan et
pas une transmission par chaîne
lamarthe a été construite expressément
pour cette raison là
après la guerre une petite série de
marthe sortie encore destinés aux civils
[Musique]
la moto la plus belle qui sans aucun
doute qui illustra le mieux cette vision
fluad gilera ça tourne une moto à
soupapes en tête conçu à salma ji en
1940 c'était une vraie moto de ballades
le rêve de beaucoup mais dont
l'équipement permis à de nombreux
particuliers de gagner d'importantes
compétitions avec un budget modeste
[Musique]
la moto de famille qui gagne les courses
était le slogan de la maison gibert
cette phrase correspondait la
philosophie de l'entreprise qui voulait
produire des motos robuste mais aussi
suffisamment performante pour participer
aux compétitions
la moto la plus belle qui sans aucun
doute illustra le mieux cette vision
puis la gilera ça tourne d'une moto à
soupapes en tête conçu à salma ji en
c'était une vraie manteau de balade le
rêve de beaucoup mais dont l'équipement
permis à de nombreux particuliers de
gagner d'importantes compétitions avec
un budget modeste
à tournon est probablement la gilera la
plus célèbre est de toute façon une des
motos les plus réputés et les plus
appréciés de l'histoire du motocyclisme
ses débuts se situe en 1947 dans les
courses en circuit de l'amour avec
bassanini qui pourtant fut obligé de
déclarer forfait
juste après une série de succès arrive
dans les années qui suivirent les motos
d'écurie et celle conduite par des
particuliers et obtiendront environ 500
victoires
[Musique]
pour
michel guyot
cependant après l'assaut tournon giléra
construisit aussi une véritable moto de
course
la première c'est tournon qui s'appelait
ça tourne au corps ça était déjà une
moto complètement différente car il
avait un cadre beaucoup plus léger sans
tube et un moteur qui par rapport au
modèle normal de 23 24 chevaux était de
36,38 chevaux
bref il s'agissait d'une véritable moto
de course
c'était un modèle aux prestations
absolument exceptionnelle et surtout ils
savent s exprimer de manière
satisfaisante sur des circuits plus
sinueux
il avait une grande accélération des
bons freins et était extrêmement
maniable
avec ce modèle la gilera gagna sur le
circuit de l'ospedale et y à san remo en
remportant cinq titres consécutifs
à partir de ce moment là le modèle qui
avance appelé corsa devint le modèle
sans raymond
[Musique]
non
et ces ghettos avec le temps la san remo
c'est ça d'être compétitive dans les
courses ou concours et des motos comme
la norton ou la liesse qui venait
d'angleterre
c'est pourquoi giléra fabrique un autre
modèle de course appelée pew mme à cause
de la légèreté du cadre
son moteur était beaucoup plus puissants
ou 40 42 chevaux à 6000 tours
avec cette moto il remporta plusieurs
titres
[Musique]
dans la foulée de la nouvelle production
de moteurs à soupapes en tête né en 1935
la série vt surnommé quatre boulons dit
par la suite évolueront à 8 moulon
lennon proviennent du nombre de boulons
qui fixe le fond du cylindre au carter
moteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette moto à participer à des courses de
1952 1957 dans la catégorie sport
démontrant une fois de plus les grandes
qualités de son moteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là ça tourne au était un bon modèle mais
plus suffisant pour participer aux
grandes compétitions du championnat du
monde
de lusine d'art corps et arriva alors la
moto qui allait permettre à giléra de
tout gagner
[Musique]
avec l'avènement de la 4 cylindres nappe
sous main fut abandonné les courses
continuèrent avec la 4 cylindres plus
performantes
[Musique]
la gilera 4 cylindres construite après
la guerre et sans aucun doute une des
motos de course les plus exemplaires et
fait partie des bolides les plus célèbre
de tous les temps
le projet né du crayon de pierrot ray
mort servira un grand succès
modifié à plusieurs reprises au fil des
ans mise à jour et amélioré par les
mains habiles des ingénieurs et
mécaniciens
elle est une légende incontesté dans
l'histoire de la moto italienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
la 500 4 cylindres à deux arbres
refroidi par air remporta une série de
titres qui la fit rentrer dans
l'histoire du sport motocycliste
on a gagné vraiment à maintes reprises
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant m me taire je me perds toujours
la hauteur
m
septembre
c'est là-bas
au jet when she seul
ma
ma mère aussi tard
je suis dans ma chambre
[Musique]
quel beau
je veux parler
la jadco
[Musique]
ont
ils été construite à rome par la
compagnie nationale d'aéronautique ichi
faillite en 1935
quand on a dû trouver une usine pour
faire avancer le projet on consulte à
différentes maisons de production parmi
lesquels moto guzzi mais personne ne
voulut acheter le projet parce que le
marché préférait les produits faits
maison
josep et gilera était d'un grand
pragmatisme
pour lui l'important c'était la
fonctionnalité du produit après il
suffisait tout simplement de l'appeler
d'hilaire
une nouvelle fois la grande intuition de
giuseppe giléra fit de reprendre le
matériel technique de la ronde in 4
cylindres turbocompressé
dessiné par mesure est mort
avec les six exemplaires de la ronde in
arrivée retard corps et pierrot ray mort
qui rôde taruffi ingénieur pilote et
pilote d'essai très estimé le chef des
mécaniciens
ce groupe fit la renommée de ces textes
seront d'hinnin co qui après avoir pris
la marque gilera devint une grande
collectionneuse de records mondiaux sur
différentes distances
[Musique]
avant herbe étaient jolies perles rouges
11h10 m
régime fasciste le régime fasciste
étaient très sensibles à toute
manifestation de supériorité dans le
domaine de l'industrie italienne
la course au record était un véritable
objectif
cela participa à la création de l'image
d'une entreprise aux capacités mécanique
d'un haut niveau
on se souviendra encore majeur celui de
la vitesse absolue qui dépassait les 274
km heure sur le parcours chronométré de
l'autoroute entre bergame et bray tient
et l'engagement fut remarquable
maintenir droite cette moto monstrueuse
au delà des 200 km fut un effort énorme
piero taruffi qu'il aura plein à maintes
reprises
la moto des records de taruffi et le
quatre cylindres turbocompressé
dérivée directement du projet c'est un
arrondi
cette machine sans le carénage participa
aux courses jusqu'à la seconde guerre
mondiale glanant quelques victoires
historiques
la 500 turbocompressé 4 cylindres devint
non seulement une grande machine à
battre des records mais aussi une grande
machine pour le grand prix
la moto des records différer un peu de
sel qui roulait sur les pistes ces
différences étaient minimes mais
importante en ce qui concerne le moteur
et le cadre
[Musique]
on
se rappelle d'une victoire importante de
la ligue réty amende ce fut la première
grande victoire de cette moto qui sur le
papier a été gagnante si on sait pas
pourquoi n'arrivait jamais à franchir la
ligne d'arrivée cette fois là elle
écrase à tout le monde avec d'orignaux
serafini pilote de pizzaro elle remporta
le titre européen battant la bm v turbo
compressé de meilleur formidable machine
pour l'époque
après la guerre les règlements des
compétitions interdisait l'utilisation
de la suralimentation
la 4 cylindres d'avant-guerre et
radicalement modifié et remplacé au
début par un quatre cylindres 500
refroidis à l'eau
ce modèle n'était pas une solution
parfaite et le personnel du département
course se remit à l'oeuvre afin de
concevoir une moto gagnante
de ce projet naquit la 500 4 cylindres à
deux arbres refroidi par air
il gagna une série de titres mondiaux
marquant de façon indélébile l'histoire
du motocyclisme italien
gilera 4 cylindres 500 et la moto de
tous les records non seulement record de
vitesse mais aussi nombre de victoires
umberto mazetti et champion du monde en
50 haies en 52 suivi par jobs duke trois
fois champion du monde et libéraux
liberati vainqueur en 1957
à cela s'ajoutent six titres mondiaux
ainsi que trois victoires au tourist
trophy huit titres italiens une victoire
et un record au milan tarente grâce à
bruno frenchies il
était la véritable reine une moto qui
évolue est continuellement
au cours de la même saison concours est
des modèles différents entre deux
versions adaptable aux différentes
caractéristiques des pistes
[Musique]
la
construction grande et gilera participa
aussi avec succès aux compétitions de
side car
la maison remporta dès victoire au grand
prix mondiaux ces résultats sont restés
dans l'histoire aussi parce que peu
nombreuses furent les marques italiennes
qui se risquèrent dans les trois roues
[Musique]
il
e
[Musique]
le gilera avait adapté le side-car au
quatre cylindres
et dans de nombreuses occasions à lhassa
tournon en modifiant radicalement le
cadre la fin de mettre toutes les
chances de son côté pour concourir avec
de bons résultats
[Musique]
l'aca tôt
l'asa tournon ne fut pas seulement une
moto de vitesse utilisés dans les
compétitions de side car
elle devra entre autres une machine de
compétition dans toutes les courses dans
le cross et dans les compétitions de
régularité
le pilote ville qui avait gagné en 1939
la milano tarento préparer une version
spéciale pour la compétition de cross
qui se dispute à imola en 1948
à partir de celle-ci n'a qu itunes ça
tourne au cross avec un engagement
direct aux courses de la maison mère
à partir de cette moto naîtra un modèle
pour les compétitions de régularité qui
n'était déjà plus tout terrain par
rapport aux modèles d'avant guerre
les compétitions de régularité était en
réalité et des compétitions de vitesse
sur route
on
à
[Musique]
après la guerre le scénario changea
complètement
des motos populaire s'imposait plus
économique et de petite cylindrée pour
pénétrer dans un marché extrêmement
concurrentiel
[Musique]
725 et la série qui l'a suivi ont fait
la fortune de l'entreprise
la cylindrée a augmenté au cours des
années et les modèles se sont
spécialisés comme pour cette épreuve de
régularité confiée au pilote officiel
[Musique]
conte
gilera commença à s'intéresser à une
moto de faible cylindrée même pour les
courses de vitesse comme 775 centimètres
cubes bicylindre formule 2
[Musique]
la 175 fut construite pour pouvoir
participer au moto de gier
il s'agissait d'une course par étapes
qui passait par quasiment toute l'italie
i qui était très populaire
c'est pourquoi giléra ne pouvait pas se
permettre de négliger une participation
à cette compétition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la vraie moto grand prix pour la
catégorie 125 né en 1956 grâce au projet
de la 175 centimètres cubes bicylindre
formule 2
[Musique]
la 125 étaient vraiment une moto conçu
pour les grands prix c'est à dire pour
les courses sur les pistes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était une moto très rapide qui à sa
première sortie à monza en mai 1956
remporta le titre elle gagna aussi
quelques compétitions internationales
mais elle n'arriva jamais à remporter le
titre mondial
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
1957 fut une année glorieuse celle du
titre mondial de libéro liberati
[Musique]
mais à la fin de la saison se produisit
ce que tout le monde à plat le pacte de
scélérat c'est à dire un accord entre
gilera goody et mondiale qui décidèrent
de se retirer du championnat du monde et
des compétitions plus généralement
on doit pas oublier que l'engagement de
gilera dans les courses était vraiment
important probablement même trop par
rapport aux dimensions de la maison de
sa production de son marché
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
les normes
[Musique]
le dernier pilote qui devint champion du
monde avant que l'entreprise ne se
retire et libéraux liberati
il atteignit la célébrité en 1957 avec
quatre victoires et un bon nombre de
classements
liberati avait déjà commencé à
participer aux courses en 44 et depuis
cette année il n'avait jamais cessé
à part en 57 il n'y pas une carrière
couronnée de succès avec 10 l'air mais
il resta fidèle à cette équipe dès le
début des années 50 libero liberati
mourut prématurément dans un accident de
la route en valny nairas en 1962 mais sa
renommée reste vivante et son nom lié à
cette saison unique pour la moto
italienne
[Musique]
il
en 1959 la maison d'art kor et célèbre
ses 50 ans pour célébrer cet
anniversaire marque aurait sorti un
modèle qui remporta un grand succès la
98 doubi les eaux
cette moto est plus importante que nous
laisse apparaître sa modeste cylindrée
c'est une moto polyvalente qui fut
ensuite produite en plusieurs modèles
elle est économique et confortable dans
sa version course de régularité elle est
connue sous le nom de scène johnny ou
six jours en français
[Musique]
une moto qui connu de nombreuses
versions tout terrain notamment pour les
épreuves de régularité et dans une
moindre mesure de cross
[Musique]
deux séries de jubilé au était notre
série leader jusqu'à l'année du passage
chez pyatt
en 1969 à cause de graves difficultés
économiques
l'entreprise est acquise par le groupe
piia tueur
[Musique]
il existe de nombreuses sources y
compris dans le secteur manufacturier
commencé aussi à produire d'autres
modèles comme la 150 hardcore et la 125
hardcore et les modèles à deux temps
sorti dans les années 80
[Musique]
brian bach et ses partenaires
là
[Musique]
gfr
on est revenu aux grosses cylindrées
répondant ainsi à la pression des
japonais
c'est moi qui ai suivi la production de
cette nouvelle ça tourne au dans un
premier temps
avec un moteur de 350 cm cube
puis de 500 centimètres cubes et au delà
ce modèle a participé aux grandes
courses africaine et a représenté le top
dans la production de gilles r
[Musique]
d
nous
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mme
gillard a poursuivi son activité dans
les tout terrain et se consacra ensuite
au grand rallye qui était devenu très à
la mode dans les années 80 et 90
elle participa au paris dakar et au
rallye des pharaons avec 1 600
monocylindre dérivé de la série la moto
fut développée elle devint une percée
750 et c'est à dire la moto qui remporta
pilotée par luigi medardo le titre dans
la catégorie silhouette au paris-dakar
de 1981
elle gagna aussi le rallye des pharaons
avec woody medardo et franck kopytko un
des héros italien du paris-dakar en 1992
puis ce fut un arrêt définitif
coïncidant aussi avec la décision de se
retirer des compétitions de vitesse
[Musique]
l'énième retour à la vitesse de la
gilera remonte à l'année 2000 avec la
125 piloté par manuel poggiali qui en
2001 remporta le titre mondial en
redorant le blason de la marque
c'était une situation différente de
celle des années 50
en effet la gilera était la fille de la
derbi qui encore aujourd'hui fait partie
du groupe piaggio
en fait la moto dessiné par la même
équipe technique courait sous deux
couleurs et deux dénominations
différentes
tout ça grâce à ganges quiros acquis qui
devint ensuite le responsable de la
technique développée au fil des années
par la maison de noël
une moto bicylindre 250
qui portait sur le réservoir et sur le
carénage
la marque giléra
remporta finalement le titre mondial en
grâce à l'étoile montante du
motocyclisme italien marco simoncelli
gagner avec ladji l'air
et devenir champion du monde cette même
année
son centième anniversaire
me fait venir la chair de poule
on s'entend de nombreux événements sont
survenus
ce fut vraiment formidable
maintenant mon nom dans la liste des
pilotes qui ont remporté le titre
mondial avec 10 les reins
comme liberati duke
qui lui aussi a été un peu mon maître
quand j'ai débuté
tout ça fait chaud au coeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il reste le mythe de la marque qui
encore aujourd'hui évoque une belle
histoire de passion sportive
c'est l'illustration de la capacité d'un
homme qui partant de zéro a su
construire une marque devenue célèbre
dans le monde
[Musique]
cet attrait
paris 10 mai
georges ralli cha cha va
il saurait que c'est arrivé
[Musique]
macho
2 mais
ce jeudi
b
[Musique]
je n'y étais pas mais
sur la durée
hélas
[Musique]
g
que c'est bon
beaucoup